yeah we're just gonna keep chumming i
think and
tee it up
now
paige has another chance to tag an oahu
tiger shark before they gather in maui
as soon as i jumped in while she's
prepping the camera
paige this is your shot this is your
shark
[Music]
i am really trying to just
let the rest of the noise that's going
on in my head kind of fade away
and i am on a level of focus that i have
not experienced before in my life
i looked over and she's already swimming
down
she's literally like at that one point
right behind the shark where he can't
quite see the back of his dorsal fin
my heartbeat in that moment was so loud
in my ears it was like i couldn't hear
anything else
and seeing it go on
right where it needs to be
the shark had no idea until
boom the clamp went on
and i was just so relieved like i was
just like
yes
i was like we did it
we didn't know what the shark was gonna
do after the tag was put on his dorsal
fin
[Music]
and then he comes back
here comes this tiger shark with a
bright orange little package and we were
just like ah now we're on his camera you
know it's so cool now the shark's
filming us
for paige
this is the culmination of years of
preparation
[Music]
the sense of relief that i felt once i
saw that the camera was on was
it was huge
i'm super proud of her
she has worked her butt off for the last
few years to make sure that this thing
is deployed on a tiger shark and she
nailed it
[Music]
paige has proven that it doesn't disturb
the shark's natural behavior in the
slightest i mean the fact that he came
back around
validates the method of tagging
it was exciting enough to see from the
shark's point of view
but then i see that he actually went and
swam up to another tiger shark
which is just
insane
it brings the proof of concept full
circle
it takes a uniquely skilled team
trained in the right way with the right
equipment and we have that team
i have no doubt that paige has the
ability to pull this off
i'm definitely ready for maui
[Music]
you